[Music]  sorry this week a Russian space capsule  carrying the Olympic torch returned  safely to earth take a look and we have  touchdown  again fielder your chicken holding the  Olympic torch  yeah well the torch has been in space  before but this was the first time it  was taken outside of the capsule on a  spacewalk  and earlier today a press conference was  held to mark that historic event check  it out okay I have time for a couple  more questions yes were you nervous  about leaving the spaceship without any  protection nervous listen to this guy  was i nervous look every precaution was  made to guarantee our experience in  outer space was completely safe and  without incident the Russian space crew  performed a series of oh oh god it hurt  so much  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  my worries if we don't do that soon  another show might do it  [Music]